Hey hip-hop veteran Joseph Carter Hannah
better known as Fat Joe is known for
many smash hits including what's love
with Ashanti and lean back he's now
ready to release his eleventh studio
album family ties your first solo album
in almost a decade well well it's
actually not a solo album it's a duet is
me and my brother Dre of cool & Dre
grace here super producer the album is
called family ties you are here in the
Toyota greenroom what up thank you so
much good to see you it's great such
great energy this morning me and you
behind the scenes talking all right Joe
which is I was like right out of college
man when that song came out and I was
like what saved my life of shout out Red
Alert it was just his birthday DJ where
I learned living legend I gave him my
promo it was like a demo a promo and he
would play it every week on on 98.7 kids
and then later came and signed me and
Chris lighty gave me a record deal and
flo-jo went number one in the country
it's just a totally interesting story
how that came about and can you I mean
when you think back to those days 93 and
where you are right now at this new
album coming out 11 studio albums all
the things it's mother solve them it's
miserable why do you say this one is it
because we just really you know I
personally feel my fans can just stone
me to death but I feel like I never had
a classic album from A to Z just Fat Joe
so I made sure that me and Dre and the
team we made this a classic album and
when we start talking about the hip-hop
gods on Mount Rushmore all these guys
had classic albums when you say nas
Illmatic
reason about reasonable doubt jay-z or
Big Pun capital punishment I've always
wanted a classic album and this is it so
great explain to me the collaboration
and sort of how you contribute to this
album and because when you're talking
about he's saying this is the greatest
album he's ever produced and you've
worked with him on that just give me a
sense of you know we've known Joe me and
cool we've known Joe for over 15 years
so he's known as
with teenagers and we've worked on a
bunch of his albums and with this one we
just felt that first of all that Joe is
the only artist from the 90s
that's still out here making hit records
and we don't really get opportunity to
shed that light on that you know I'm
saying so with this new single yes he
did it again another top-ten single and
with this album we just knew that it was
important for him to hit that last
second shot and come home with the
trophy like MJ nice nice what do you
mean the last-second shot what does that
mean it means I'm almost out of here I
think I'm retiring wait wait wait get up
getting it now I'm trying to walk off on
that I'm trying to say you're not really
pro bono to Obama drop the mic and walk
or I might be you might be I'm really
there yeah I've never felt like this in
my life you know my daughter's turning
40 man I really want to watch my
daughter you know I really want to you
know take her to school every day watch
her make sure she's like that's really
the conflict you know that's where I'm
conflicted at you know the women not
women but little girls 13 14 very
impressionable right now so I want to
make sure every time she turned around
her dad is there when she looks around
and I'm there for family ties family
ties right and you had a very touching
message message about your son Joey he's
got autism autism yes shared that with
the millions of your fans and you spoke
very movingly about it on Instagram well
you know I feel like all my blessings
come from Joey you know what I mean when
he was born he was autistic
his mom's was like yo I can't do this
I'm ready to give him up for adoption
so I raised him with my mother and my
father and he's the happiest kid in the
world he's just so happy and he blesses
us I really truly believe he's our
blessing you know
so you thinking this might be the time
to spend some time with you got it got
it good I'm thinking I'm I love the
hip-hop is crazy he doesn't believe me
but he's never heard me say this like
and I've got mad at all the other
rappers who said they're retiring I make
that cut like way to know I'm a strong
advocate
against that job really I've been
flirting with it I'm like a 85% gone
like you know
so what this mean though that I mean
you're not doing TV you're in movies
you're talking about eventually leaving
it all behind or maybe no no no no no
okay
it's gonna be TV we just sold the movie
the Warner Brothers we create in series
we just work in man yes in you in night
school it was that fun so much fun man
there was someone's fun and I learned so
much from them those guys it was it was
an incredible opportunity man I thought
I knew acting and when I got around
Kevin Hart and Tiffany Haddish and
everybody I was like well I bring who I
was like oh my god you could do that I
was like oh my god they opened up a
Pandora's box and I loved it that's
great so let's real talk quickly about
the album so in addition to having super
producer Dre on it with you you got some
other collaborations on on the record
newly announced of that family some
family arrived late but they show up
when you need them Remi Mars on the
album late entry who we got Eminem we
got Allison Jeremiah that car cardi and
and and even though we mentioned into
all these collaborations the album
doesn't sound like put together album
it's like dr. Dre chronic is the best
way to explain it to you because when he
does his music different people pop out
of different hooks and different bridges
and all almost Kanye West Kanye Kanye
West's like where he'll have Kenny G
playing at the end and you'll be like
water Kenny G that's kind of like the
Bob this album is excellent excellent
well let me ask you this before we wrap
this up we were talking a little before
the camera started rolling about what
your life story would look like if you
ever decided to put a pen to paper I
mean you've been talking to
about life in your rappin ever since
back in the day but if you actually
thought about the arc of your career and
where you are right now with family with
friends with the people that are working
on your records right now how would you
sort of synthesize all that and that's
hard to do in just one small moment but
uh it's just been a complete struggle
it's been fighting you know I grew up in
the South Bronx and the projects we call
it the mud I grew up from nothing nobody
ever gave me nothing
I was three times this size sneaking
into record Lee was walking up 31
flights of stairs giving them my demo
they turned around and tell me I'm
garbage yeah I walked back down but I
never gave up I think it was it would be
it would it we just found it never give
up never be like Fat Joe never gave up
you never gave up no matter what
excellent one last thing you look great
hey man let me tell you you look great
you know I've been on a diet for three
days good Thanksgiving I'm pitching that
blow I swear to God no really not even
on the flight when they give you a
little peanut egg whites this morning
yeah because you've talked about health
is the new wealth that's right oh
there's the new wealth that's all it is
man you know we trying to do and you
know I got a nephew I got a nephew he's
still 6 X and back in the day you could
walk in any store in the hood and by 6 X
Coast I'm buying a coke for my nephew I
went to 20 stores nobody says that's no
more I'm going all around all the fat
guys stores nobody 6x everybody stood
some weight man this is crazy good to
see you man Family Ties coming out on
Friday wherever you like to get your
music family ties check it out
that's Joe in the